[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor hi
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
on november 20 2021 traffic came to a
sudden standstill on one of california's
busiest freeways after an armored car
accidentally spilled several bags of
cash across the interstate
several drivers and passengers slammed
on their banks and jumped out of their
vehicles on the busy highway just north
of san diego to grab what they could
when the california highway patrol
arrived at the scene they arrested two
people and warned some others who could
not resist the temptation to grab the
money
videos across social media showed plenty
of people scooping up handfuls of cash
mostly ones and twenties
fortunately these videos also captured
the faces and license plates of the
event
the chp are working with the fbi to
identify those who greedily exploited
the accident
it's amazing how quickly many honest
citizens were overcome by the love of
money
you know pastor ross you can't help but
wonder
what would you do if you're driving down
the road and all of a sudden you see
yourself surrounded by a sea of bills
currency maybe you consider it answer to
prayer and get out and grab a bag and
start filling up no you don't want to do
that
but yeah what a temptation of course you
can you can see how the folks are all
excited
it's not really their money i mean they
they've got to turn it in legally you
can find it in your pocket exactly and
you know we've all heard stories about
some you know very honest citizens that
find like a a bag of money with no id
and they take it to the police station
and lo and behold it was some dear old
person savings that had fallen out of
the car whatever
and there are you know some honest
people out there fortunately but you
know the bible tells us in the last days
evil men and seducers will wax worse and
worse and you can read
in first timothy 6
for the love of money is a root of all
kinds of evil for which some have
strayed from the faith in their
greediness and pierce themselves through
with many sorrows
you know when a person is converted not
only is their heart converted for
spiritual things but god converts your
wallet as well
and one of the ways you know that a
person has been born again is just their
their generosity they're not controlled
by covetousness or greed anymore
and they're willing to share and they're
willing if they find something that's
not theirs they'll automatically think
well this dear person whoever it is they
lost some money
you know your heart goes out to that
poor armored truck driver who forgot to
latch the back door
and uh he may have lost his job right
right well you know pastor we do have a
study guide that talks about the
christian and money and of course as you
mentioned the bible verse the love of
money is the root of all evil and that's
that's so true in our world today but
what does the bible say about how we can
be faithful stewards for the things that
god has given us we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks this
is our free offer for this evening it's
a study guide called in god we trust if
you'd like to receive that the number to
call is 800-835-6747
and you can just ask for offer number
135 or you can ask for the study guide
by name it's called in god we trust
we'll be happy to send it to anyone in
north america if you're watching outside
of north america we know we have people
who are tuning in
on the various social media networks or
they're watching on a various channel um
you can just go to the amazing facts
website just
amazingfacts.org.com and you'll be able
to enroll in our free bible school and
you'll actually be studying this lesson
again it's called in god we trust or
maybe it's a good time just to greet
those who are joining us you know we
have folks watching on youtube as
mentioned on social media folks
listening on the radio we have people
listening on satellite radio so for
those who've always listened to the
program we want to make sure you're
aware we are broadcasting and you can
see what's happening here in the studio
just simply go to the doug batchelor
facebook page or the amazing facts
facebook page also on youtube and on
amazingfactstv that's right
and you can send your questions and also
on the facebook page as well
okay well we're gonna get right to our
questions if you have a bible related
question the number to call here to the
studio is 800-463-7297
that'll bring you a call here in the
studio and of course if you don't get
right through uh just stay on the phone
one of our operators will get to you as
soon as they can well before we get the
questions let's start with prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study and father as we always
do we want to ask for the holy spirit to
be with us be with pastor doug and
myself here in the studio as we answer
these questions and we pray that you'd
be with those who are listening or
watching wherever they might be
father the purpose of this program of
this time is to come to a clear and full
understanding of your word
for we are reminded of what jesus said
they shall know the truth and the truth
will set them free so father keep us
clear and bless this program in jesus
name amen amen all right well we're
going to go to our first caller this
evening we've got peter listening in
canada peter welcome to bible answers
live
i'm so happy to talk to you about the
dog and pastor ross i've been listening
to your messages for a while i'm like
still at either just though i really
love the messages that thank god for
your work
well thank you for calling and your
question tonight
okay so
i've been you know with the
your new um summit that amazing fact is
doing you know i'm talking about
evolution
um i like science i like sodium science
and i um
i like to see um the studies of like
nasa and
those discovering life in other planets
but like
if they were to discover life in another
planet what would they make for the
bible
all right so if they were to discover
life on another planet
would that uh impact the bible or
contradict the teachings of the bible in
some way
no because i believe the bible tells us
that god does have life on other planets
i'm sure peter you've been tracking if
you like space and exploration
that recently i think in the end of 2021
they launched the james webb telescope
which is like 100 times more powerful
than the hubble and it will be very
exciting to see it looks like it's fully
deployed now and they're doing some
calibrating
should be getting some incredible
pictures from that telescope in oh i
think about six months they said
but um
i'm probably as interested as anybody i
i'm fascinated with astronomy and the
cosmos that god made um
everything the bible says you know the
lord made the heaven and the earth he
made the stars he made it all and i
don't think the bible teaches the only
life is here on earth i believe the
scriptures say that christ made the
worlds is that hebrews chapter hebrews
chapter one and it's uh actually the
verse you're referring to there is uh
hebrews 1 verse 2. yeah in colossians it
tells about other life and revelation
talks about the creatures in heaven that
praise the lord so
we believe there is life on another
planet i'm not you know i'm not uh
too
sure that they're gonna find life on
mars or or in our solar system just
because it seems like it's such a stark
environment out there but i'm sure there
is life
the life on other planets does not
communicate with
us here on earth other than angels and
god because
we've got this disease of sin so you
might say we're sort of quarantined
here but
i think once we're saved and in the new
kingdom we're gonna
as it says in that song rock of ages
will soar two worlds unknown
you know pastor we got that story in the
book of job it talks about a gathering
of the sons of god and we know that this
didn't happen on earth because satan
came as a representative of the earth
that's right so it seems at least from
that verse that they are these other
intelligent beings from other worlds
called the sons of god here in that
passage so yeah they are intelligent
beings other than angels that god
created in the universe great q a
question peter uh next quarter that we
have is anthony listening in new york
anthony welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors um
my question
uh the best verse i could find to base
it on is exodus chapter 25 verse 40.
um and it
says uh and look that thou and this is
god talking to abraham and look that
down make them after
their pattern which was shown show thee
in the mount
and uh my understanding is that's
talking about the heavenly the earthly
sanctuary being made after the pattern
of the heavenly sanctuary so
my question is uh i know that the
earthly sanctuary only came into play
or the whole sacrificial system came
into play only after adam and eve sinned
but does that also mean that there was
really no need for heavenly sanctuary if
it was only for the atonement for sin
until after adam and eve sinned was that
create was the heavenly sanctuary also
established with the plan of salvation
yeah well you know there's some there's
some mystery to that because when you
talk about the sanctuary you're talking
about the dwelling place of god the
dwelling place of god or wherever the
capital of the universe is
has existed you know through eternity
as far as we're concerned
it was mobilized for the purpose of
saving the human race these creatures
made in god's image
or was developed i should say
probably
was it revelation says the lamb slain
from the foundation of the world
and there's other verses that talk about
the plan of salvation that you know god
knew that this would happen
back in eternity
but
it wasn't really activated with the
blood of christ until jesus died on the
cross but the pattern that god gave
moses on the mountain
is patterned after a much bigger
uh
center of god's throne
in heaven
let me give you an example
um
you've probably heard of matchbox cars
they're just like little microcosms of
big cars in the earthly sanctuary you've
got two golden angels on top of this box
well those angels are
real angels you read about in like
isaiah chapter six
and then you have the wallpaper was
with the angels on it in the holy of
holies but um they're going to be real
angels surrounding the throne of god in
heaven and instead of it being 20 feet
across it's going to be you know maybe
20 light years across i don't know but
it's it's a much bigger
reality than the model that god gave to
moses
so yeah i think it is very real
it wasn't clearly when god first
established his throne god wasn't doing
it where they were you know there was
sacrifice going on in the heavenly
temple it was used for that after the
sacrifice of christ yeah it seems like
as you mentioned pastor like there was
maybe a remodeling of the heavenly
throne room because of sin and the focus
then is to redeem mankind what is
interesting after the 1000 years you
read about in revelation 21 uh the new
jerusalem comes down the earth is
recreated describes the new jerusalem
and when sin and sin is on or more then
john in revelation 21 22 says talking
about the new jerusalem and i saw no
temple therein for the lord god almighty
in the lamb or the temple of it it's as
if the purpose of the sanctuary the
heavenly sanctuary has met its
fulfillment because sin and sin is on a
more the righteous are redeemed forever
we united with god it doesn't mean that
you know the dwelling place of god
disappears no but the the function of
the temple the work of the temple has
met its fulfillment right and that's at
the end of the thousand years after all
things are made new absolutely you know
we do have a study guide that talks
about the sanctuary and the heavenly
sanction it's called god drew the plants
and it talks about this work of
redemption and how that's playing out in
heaven as well as on the earth we'll be
able to send it to anyone who calls and
asks one of the amazing facts study
guides just call and ask 800-835
and again you can ask for the study
guide it's god drew the plans and it's
all about the sanctuary as revealing the
work of redemption thanks for your call
anthony we've got uh rose listening from
new york rose welcome to the program
good evening pastors evening
the number 40 is mentioned quite a bit
in the bible
um for example it rained 40 days and 40
nights during the flood jesus fasted 40
days a night elijah traveled to my
sunlight for 40 days so my question is
what is the significance of the number
all right very good
uh you know as near as we can tell the
number 40 represents a generation
and it's often a time of testing
for example when jesus went the
wilderness that was a time of testing
when the children of israel went through
the wilderness for 40 years that was a
time of testing
when the
12 spies explored the promised land for
40 years it was a time of testing
um and elijah i mean 40 days 40 days
sorry yeah and when elijah went uh 40
days and 40 nights to
mount sinai so it was symbolic of a
generation
uh when it's years it's 40
40 years as a generation we had a
question that came in yesterday about
why the why the blood of the um
slaughter that you see in revelation is
60 it runs 1600 furlongs which is 40
times 40.
and that was interesting it's like the
final judgment on the wicked and you
know pastor something else about 40 is
you've got three individuals that appear
together in the new testament jesus on
the mount of transfiguration and they
appeared with him moses and elijah and
it's interesting jesus fasted for 40
days
moses didn't eat for 40 days when he was
on the mount receiving the 10
commandments he was supernaturally
sustained by god and elijah was given
angel food you remember that story and
then he went in the strength of that
meal for 40 days without food yeah so
you got moses elijah and jesus all of
which went without food for 40 days and
there they together on the mount of
transfiguration so it's kind of
interesting again 40 is the time of
testing purifying
so hope that helps a little bit rose but
you're you're absolutely right and i
think pastor ross we have a website
called bible prophecy truth
and at that website there is a list of
bible numbers and their meanings that's
right and of course 40 is just one of
some other very significant bible
numbers so take a look at that just go
to the website called prophecy truth
bible prophecy bible prophecy yeah bible
prophecy truth and that's not just the
numbers there but i think the symbols
bible symbols also on the website and a
lot of additional resources next quarter
that we have is hannah listening from
louisiana hannah welcome to the program
yes i'm right here um
for background i'm a 16 year old
teenager growing in the word i'm not the
as not as knowledgeable as probably some
of the other people who called in
earlier but anyway i'm very interested
in baptism and i've been a christian for
quite a while and i've known bits and
pieces of the bible like read devotions
for quite a long time
and my dad has really instilled me in
getting more involved in the church like
learning more about his troops and i've
been watching more amazing facts with
doug batchelor programs and i heard his
testimony recently too it's very
interesting and
and that brings me to the fact that i
really want to get baptized i really
want to get into god's family and so one
day i could be one part of the 144
thousand
so my question is what does god expect
of me after baptism
oh great yeah we appreciate your
question well first of all the the um
it's wonderful that you're wanting to
make that decision and consecrate
yourself you not only want water baptism
you want spirit baptism jesus said
unless you're born of the water and the
spirit you cannot enter the kingdom of
heaven so you need both
and
but the promise is that if you receive
him to those that received him to them
he gives power that power is the power
of the person of the holy spirit in your
life to them he gives power to become
sons and daughters of god
and so when you receive him he brings
his spirit into your life you want to
then continue
bathing in that spirit just like you
know any average person you don't just
bathe once you want to continue to bathe
in the spirit
read the word
uh for a baby to grow you need to do
three things baby's got to
eat
the baby needs to breathe
and the baby needs to exercise
and if a baby is you know eating
drinking
if it's
exercising and breathing it will grow
if you are feeding on god's word
if you are breathing in prayer
and if you are sharing your faith with
others
you will grow
and so
uh do what you can to learn more about
studying the bible if you want to take
the amazing facts bible study course
that's a great place to start
spend regular time in prayer just
consecrated prayer and then talk to god
through the day in your prayers and then
look for opportunities to share what
jesus has done for you
and
you will grow in your faith and he'll
reveal what his plan is for your life
absolutely well you know we do have a
study guide maybe you're aware of this
hannah or for anyone wanting to learn
more about bible baptism what does the
bible say
one of our study guides is called purity
and power and it's about baptism jesus
said he said to nicodemus except you are
born of water and of the spirit so we
want to have water baptism but we also
want to be baptized by the spirit and
this study guide will tell you more
about that if you'd like to receive it
the number to call is
800-835-6747 it's free just ask for the
study guide on baptism it's called
purity and power we'll be happy to send
it to anyone in north america
we've got brett listening in atlanta
georgia brett welcome to the program
uh yeah my question is kind of relates
to job one and
when
satan
goes where it goes with to meet god with
the elders
who are the elders the who are the sons
of god in that yeah well you know that
came up a little bit earlier in another
question but
it appears that
when you look in
luke
chapter 3 and it talks about
you know enos was the son of seth who is
the son of adam who was the son of god
adam who was the leader of this world
was referred to as a son of god
and
god probably has
leaders of other worlds and these 24
elders around the throne
they could have been
some of the representatives of other
world or other galaxies i don't know but
some other celestial leaders
that god has in this council
and uh you know it seems to indicate
that some of the ancient israeli kings
had like 12 judges
in america i think we've got nine
justices but
they like had 12 judges that would
assist the king
and uh you know maybe that tradition
came from what's going on in heaven
but um pastor ross any thoughts on that
and we do have a book yeah that's what
i'm looking for i was going to ask you
yeah it's called who are the sons of god
yeah alien angel or adopted who are the
sons of god okay and of course that'll
get into both what you're talking about
in job and then also revelation chapter
4 we talk about the the 24 elders and
it's really a great study well thanks
for your call brad we've got uh caleb
listening in new york caleb welcome to
the program
yes i have a question um
first of all i want to thank you for
your um
you know
for everything because like um i learned
a lot from you from your teaching and
everything but i just need to know how
do i
i need to learn because like i grew up
in the faith
but i need to learn like how to fast
um how is that like a sermon you have on
fasting and how to pray and my second
question is
does fasting and prayer help you
have a stronger faith and stronger like
relationship
with
god because you know i just
feel lately i haven't been feeling you
know i have a good relationship with god
lately so
i just need to know what
does fasting help yes uh well
jesus said in the gospel of matthew and
i think it may be chapter 6 pastor ross
when he said when you fast he doesn't
say if you fast he said when you fast
feel not like the hypocrites of course
jesus said and when you pray he didn't
say if you pray said when you pray
meaning it was thoroughly understood
that they would be praying
and when he talked about fasting he said
when you fast he didn't say if you fast
fasting and prayer and then also when
john the baptist came to jesus disciples
and said how come your disciples don't
fast jesus said well when the
bridegroom's taken away they will fast
so christ always understood that prayer
and times of fasting and prayer is part
of the christian discipline for a couple
of reasons well several one there are
certain health benefits in fasting
occasionally
and that's been proven by science that
it's just good for your metabolism to
sometimes abstain and let your digestive
system recover
rather than it being you know constantly
under a burden of processing food
so there's health benefit there is
self-discipline benefit whenever you
deny yourself something that the flesh
wants
it actually it actually it strengthens
your resolve to deny yourself
and
it's not a bad practice first of
self-discipline
and then the third reason is when you
you go a day or so without eating food
or eating very carefully your mind
clears up a little bit because some of
the energy that normally goes to
digestion is now available for your
thinking
and it actually can you know in increase
your spiritual uh reception
so a lot of people who fast say i just
sense the presence of god more
uh you're basically saying lord i'm
denying the flesh because i want to
strengthen the spirit now i do have a
sermon
that you will find online and it's you
just type into google doug batchelor
when you fast
and are doug batchelor fasting and i'm
sure there are many other pastors that
have good messages on that as well
but uh you're on the right track caleb
seek after god with fasting and prayer
you may not be able to go you know a
whole day without a meat without eating
if you've not done it before you may
just start and say i'm only going to do
one meal today or
or skip the food and just you know drink
some fruit juice to keep your blood
sugar up there's several different ways
to fast and and you'll hear more about
that in the message
okay thanks for call caleb we've got uh
martin marty listening from new york
marty welcome to the program
bypasses god bless you and
uh my question is this what happens to a
christian between the time they die
and the time lord jesus comes back
well for a believer when they die their
next conscious thought is the
resurrection the bible tells us in first
thessalonians chapter 4 that the lord
himself will descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel
the trump of god and the dead in christ
will rise
and jesus said that they will live again
in the last day there it is on the
screen the dead in christ will rise
first then we who are alive and remain
shall be caught up together with them in
the clouds
so if a believer dies they've got no
consciousness of time
but life goes on here on earth until the
resurrection the resurrection has not
happened yet it is a future event
jesus i think goes three times in john
chapter six and pastor ross might find
some of those were where jesus said
i will raise him up the last day i will
raise him up the last day they'll be
raised up the last day
sometimes known as the day of the lord
it's the second coming
and
so for those who are believers that die
there's no awareness of time for them
the next thing they know is absent from
the body they're present with the lord
they're caught up they see god come they
are raised with a glorified body
the bible says it's like a moment the
twinkling of an eye
but as far as us here on earth we still
live in time it hasn't happened yet
so some people are confused they'll walk
around and say well so-and-so is in
heaven now
well as far as they're concerned they're
going to be their next thing they know
but it hasn't happened yet for us
because we still live in time and jesus
hasn't come
in other words the bible describes then
death as a sleep an unconscious sleep
the very next thing you know the second
coming of christ and you're resurrected
but you're not in heaven at the moment
right yeah while life is going on on
earth yeah it's normal and there's a
really good verse in first corinthians
chapter 15
when it tells us that um
you know when we die
um then that we're not aware of anything
until the lord comes and it tells us
that
the
a resurrected
come back to life
when the lord returns and you'll find
that in first corinthians chapter 15.
you know we do have a book talking about
well what happens when a person dies and
it's called are the dead really dead and
it looks at these different bible
teachings and different scriptures on
this yeah pastor there's a lot of
confusion out there in the world today
about the dead and sometimes people
believe well the person is asleep so to
speak the unconscious sleep waiting for
the resurrection others believe that you
receive your reward immediately and
you're in heaven or if you're a bad
person you're burning in hell well
that's what the bible teaches yes there
is a heaven and there is a final
destruction of the wicked and hell fire
but that hasn't happened yet right
so jesus says when he comes he'll bring
his reward with him to give to every man
according to his works it's revelation
22 and of course he hasn't come yet so
people have not received the reward
exactly reward would be eternal life for
the righteous and eternal death for the
wicked
well thanks for your call uh marty we
appreciate that you know pastor we got
uh looks like 20 seconds before we're
going to take our break so friends don't
go away we're just going to take a quick
break here in the studio and be back
with more of your bible questions if you
have a question the number to call is
800-463-7297 that'll bring you right in
here to the program so just after a few
moments some important announcements and
then we'll be back for more bible
answers live so don't go far we'll be
right back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
doug batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control
his search eventually led him to a cave
above palm springs that became his home
while doug scavenged for food and
garbage bins his father owned a yacht a
learjet and an airline
but in his cave home he discovered a
dust-covered bible
as he began to read he soon learned of
his true purpose in life
the richest caveman is the extraordinary
true story of doug batchelor that tells
how a rebellious teenager who once lived
in a cave became a tremendous soul
winner for jesus christ it's a thrilling
testimony of the transforming power of
god's word to order your copy of the
richest caveman call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
millions of people believe that planet
earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world cities into
chaos
in response
thinking people everywhere are wondering
if it might be a good time to locate
their families outside of the congested
metropolitan areas
in my new book heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to country living i do
my best to provide a biblical balance
i'd like to share with you some of the
crucial things you'll need to know
before you head up for the hills i'd
also like to identify some of the
practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living
order your copy of heading for the hills
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible-related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 pm
and 8 p.m pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you've tuned in
along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
where we are taking your questions and
we're going to be on the air for about
another 28 minutes
and if you want to call in with a
question the number is 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
you can also uh watch what's happening
on facebook it's on the doug batchelor
facebook page or the amazing facts
facebook page or youtube and we are
broadcasting on television on af tv
that's the amazing facts television
channel
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross and we have cynthia that is
listening in mississippi cynthia welcome
to the program
god bless both of you
um
i have someone very dear to me that
shook their own life
and
i am wondering
um i've discussed this with
my preacher and quite a few other
um creatures and
i can't seem to get a direct answer
uh i guess what i'm wanting to know is
are they
in heaven or will they stay in hell are
they in hell and will i ever see them in
heaven
all right
good question i'll try and give you a
direct answer on one aspect that you ask
there
uh are they in hell
no nobody is in hell yet
nobody is in the lake of fire that
doesn't happen until after the second
coming and you read that in revelation
20. so
every grave that says r.i.p rest in
peace the dead are sleeping until the
resurrection and jesus said the hour is
coming it's future this is john chapter
5 the hour is coming in which all that
are in the graves will hear his voice
and come forth they that have done good
the resurrection of life they have done
evil the resurrection of condemnation
so
they're not experiencing any reward
right now
will they be in heaven well you know we
have to be very careful not to judge
but i'll be honest with you that in most
cases not in all cases but in most cases
when a person takes their own life
it's because they've reached a point of
hopelessness and they've lost faith and
faith is crucial to salvation
uh you know it is true that um
the bible says that we shall not murder
and that of course would include
yourself
and part of the reason i say this
cynthia there are people listening right
now that contemplate suicide and i want
to discourage them from doing that
now there are some exceptions you have
some people i did a funeral for a young
lady that um
she was a christian became very
discouraged there may have been some
chemical imbalance took some pills after
she took the pill she called
911 and said i don't know what i was
thinking i took all these pills and
they rushed her to emergency and tried
to save her
and she was conscious when they first
got there but she slipped under and she
died
and so the family was saying you know
what are the chances i said well you
know she was probably praying and and
asking for help before this happened
so i know people i think pastor ross
does too
that they're suffering so much from some
terminal illness that they're just not
themselves and they might take their own
life
that doesn't mean that their whole life
of serving god is going to be forgotten
because of those closing hours of you
know incoherency or pain
so you have to be very careful to say
well we know what happened to a person
because only god knows their hearts
now that may sound like other answers
you've had cynthia that are
meandering back and forth but i hope
that made sense you know we do have a
book it's called choosing life because
we do get this question that people call
in and ask and uh it's an important
subject so i just recently passed today
you finished the book it's called
choosing life and it talks about uh what
do you do if a loved one or family
member or somebody you might know is
contemplating suicide how do we
encourage them and point them in the
right direction we'll be happy to send
that book out to anyone who calls and
asks it's a new book so you need to ask
for it it's called choosing life and the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the new book called
choosing life and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone in north america
thank you again for your call cynthia
we've got stephen listening in canada
steven you're on the air
oh hello pastor doug and pastor john
ross thanks for having me yes
um so
my question
it's um
it's a little complex
hopefully i'll be able to put this out
simply
the the word um regarding perfection um
so it said that we see in job that it
says job was a perfect you know upright
man i guess the word they're blameless
that says same thing about noah perfect
or um blameless and it says regarding
140 or 4 thousand they're blameless the
people that wash their robes some
they're blameless before the um before
the throne of god um obviously jesus was
the ultimate of perfection he was
sinless our lord and savior
um what i've i've listened to like your
sermons pastor doug about like how
perfect must a christian be i remember
you i can't remember you said something
about i don't believe in perfection in
this sense but i do
anyways i won't speak too much more just
the word perfection what does how
perfect
should a christian be what what does
that relate to in the bible because it
even god said come before me abraham and
be perfect like that word perfection all
these different contexts i see in the
bible and stuff oh that's good
yeah good question it's a practical
question and i'm really thankful for the
stories in the bible because the lord
you just highlighted abraham and others
who were declared perfect
and then you see while god looked upon
them as consistently serving him
you know abraham he goes to egypt and
lies and says sarah is really his sister
because he's afraid
and then he gets talked into taking his
concubine as a wife
the bible tells us about zechariah and
elizabeth in the new testament it says
they were perfect walking in all the
commandments of the lord right after it
says they were perfect uh he struck dumb
for his lack of faith
and so
being perfect biblically doesn't mean
you that you're flawless and that's
where i think some people get
discouraged
because especially young people they
they think oh man i've got to be
flawless
i've got to be some kind of a biblical
saint before i can be saved
and
then you read and you find out that you
know there'll be people in heaven like
peter who you know made some big
mistakes and
and paul and moses
who um you know these
god filled elijah with the holy spirit
and he prayed and fire and rain came
down from heaven and a little while
later he said oh lord take my life he
got discouraged and he ran
but elijah went to heaven and a fiery
chariot
so these are people who had surrendered
themselves to the lord they were
committed to serving god
but you do see that they were very human
now as a christian our example is a
perfect example that's a jesus so we
should always strive to be christ-like
chances are we're going to stumble and
fall along the way but
we you never make excuses for sin
because we're longing and loving
holiness that's the key to happiness now
i hope that made sense
thank you
if yeah if i had to be a stainless steel
sterile robot who never
did anything wrong or felt any
temptation then there'd be no hope for
me but i can live with christian joy and
assurance because i believe that god
begins at work in me and as i cooperate
with him he is working out his salvation
in me
all right excellent thank you stephen
for your call we've got grace listening
from new jersey grace welcome to the
program
yes hi pastors hi pastor doug
a blessing to speak to you
likewise
yes uh i have a question uh let me give
you the verse it's uh
revelation 2022
but outside are dogs and sorcerers and
sexually immoral and murderers idolaters
and who whoever loves and practice a lie
yeah
my question is i listened to your ten
commandments um
you know that someone you had the series
and i remember you mentioning also about
the
the dogs when
i directed they belong outside and my
question here is because
i see
people who have dogs inside the house
and some people call them children and
this is my baby
and i don't know how to address that
issue
okay is that great now first of all in
revelation when it says for outside our
dogs
dogs is a term that was used uh for
people
that were just carnally minded that had
turned from god it's not talking about
fido it's not talking about canine
animals
paul talks in philippians i think he
says beware of the dogs and he's talking
and that's yeah beware of dogs and evil
workers philippians 3 2.
two animals that were scavengers that
are often referred to by the children of
israel were pigs and dogs
now you're not supposed to eat either
one that god you know dogs are
scavengers dogs it says they ate jezebel
so um a dog was considered an unclean
animal but
uh people had dogs even in the bible
as pets because you can remember when
a woman came to jesus and said will you
please heal my my daughter and jesus
said it's not appropriate to take the
children's food and give it to the dogs
she said yes but even the dogs eat the
crumbs that fall from the children's
tables now that must be a household dog
if they're doing that so there's no sin
against owning a dog and some people are
lonely
i would agree that in some cases people
go a little far and they kind of treat
their dogs with
more love than they do humans
and
i went to hong kong and people buy fur
coats for their dogs and walk them up
and down the street with
golden collars and you know it just gets
really carried away
but
no there's no sin in having a pet
but a dog is
in its wild state is considered a
scavenger and that's why it talks about
the dogs outside the new jerusalem
and of course back in bible times uh the
jew considered all other people unclean
and even referred to them as as being
dogs referring to the unbelievers and in
the prophetic sense when you're reading
revelation it's talking about dogs
outside the city it's talking about
those who are unbelieving yeah those who
have rejected the grace of god it's just
a symbol and even goliath said to david
am i a dog that you're coming to me with
a stick it was considered like a low
animal
so
yeah but there's no sin in having a dog
as a pet some people have pigs as pets
and i that's where i draw the line
okay
all right thanks we got david who's
listening in california david welcome to
the program
okay so i know loved ones um and friends
that are part of congregations where
false doctrine is being preached um
would it be wrong to tell them to come
out of those congregations uh where
false doctrine is being taught
and that's a reference according to uh
revelation 18 4.
okay let's read revelation 18 4 and it
says here and i heard a voice from
heaven saying come out of her my people
lest you share in her sins unless you
receive of her plagues for her sins have
reached to heaven this is verse 5 and
god has remembered her iniquities yeah
certainly it's dangerous when a person
is sitting under
false teaching now there's scarcely a
church out there that could say our
teachings are perfect and i know as a
pastor i've said things in church and i
preach things and years later i thought
oh lord maybe i was wrong on that
and you know you you have to realize
that
preachers are not
they don't claim to be all knowing so
it's one thing to say you know preacher
made a mistake in something or there's
some doctrines that you know there might
be some
uh freedom of disagreement on but on the
fundamentals if if a a church is
teaching something that is
undermines one of the fundamentals of
christianity
regarding salvation and being a
christian
then it's not healthy for a person to
stay under that teaching if you've got
friends or family that are in that
category you ought to study with them
and show them what the particular issues
are you can't just say you got to come
out of that church because they're
teaching
heresy
study show them they've got to see it
for themselves so they can make their
own decisions in the future based on the
word not on your word
so
i hope that helps david we would take a
second question but we see several
people are lined up so i appreciate your
understanding
we've got kevin listening in maryland
kevin welcome to the program
thank you pastors um tonight i was
curious on um how do we reconcile that
if the sabbath was set up at a time when
uh the seventh day was based on the
lunar calendar how do we now reconcile
that being locked in with the gregorian
calendar
well the a change of the calendar
doesn't change the weekly cycle
so why it is true that the jews operated
with a lunar calendar
they had approximately 360 days in their
year some people are thinking well
wouldn't that throw you off after a few
years yes but they knew that and then
they would add a month i think it was
every 12 or 13 years they added a month
to reconcile the seasons once again
but that doesn't affect the weekly cycle
the weekly cycle is simply a series of
one two three four five six seven
people get confused because they see the
days of the week printed on the calendar
with the month and they think if you
change the calendar it changes the
weekly cycle no matter what you do to
the calendar whether it's a solar or a
lunar calendar
the days beginning at creation to the
present have gone in a sequence of one
through seven one through seven one
through seven there is nothing
in history
that shows that any change of the
calendar has affected the weekly cycle
that the jews observed
so i i hope that helps a little bit
kevin i appreciate that you know we've
got a i think there's a book that um
i hope we have it in our library if not
you'll find it online our friend steve
wohlberg wrote a book on lunar sabbath
and if you type in steve wolberg lunar
sabbath you might find that
and he he goes into the sabbath and the
lunar calendar in that book
all right next quarter that we have is
is uh rhonda listening from tennessee
rhonda welcome to the program
thank you good evening um my question
tonight is on ezekiel 36 verses 26 and
and this is an experience that i have
been
praying for and longing for in my life
for some time
but i just don't see a change and i'm
still struggling with the same old sins
i'm the same old person and so i'm
wondering why
and if i'm doing something wrong or what
could be the cause
well let me read the verse for our
friends who are listening
it says in verse i'll start with verse
then i will sprinkle clean water on you
and you will be clean and i will cleanse
you from all of your filthiness and all
of your idols i will give you a new
heart and put a new spirit within you
i'll take away the heart of stone out of
your flesh and give you a heart of flesh
i'll put my spirit within you and cause
you to walk in my statutes and you will
keep my judgments and do them
now that is basically describing the new
covenant this is the ezekiel version
there's also a jeremiah version where he
talks about you know writing his law in
our hearts and i think that's what
you're describing here
rhonda is that you you're looking for
that new birth experience
do not be discouraged if you pray for
that and you strive for that and it
seems like you haven't found it right
away
um
i was just this week listening to some
great quotes by some preachers
matter of fact
the great preacher charles spurgeon
struggled with his own salvation when he
was a young man he kept thinking he'd
pray and he'd fall and he'd pray and
he'd fall and he thought i'm never going
to have the new birth experience
and he walked into a little church on a
rainy day this country preacher was
preaching from the verse in isaiah
that said in
chapter i believe it's chapter 42
or 45 22
look unto me all the ends of the earth
and be saved
and
continue to look at jesus and believe
that he saves you we do not do the good
things
to be saved
but as we trust in his keeping his
promise his salvation
we then do the good things because we
believe he has saved us
and so
if you don't start right and you're
thinking about salvation
you're going to really believe it's your
work that does it it's his work that
does it for you
and so keep thanking him and trusting
that in his mercy keep looking to him
you know christ said to nicodemus you've
got to be born again
and then jesus said in john 3 15
as moses lifted up the serpent even so
the son of man must be lifted up you
remember the people were bitten by the
serpents and they looked at this bronze
serpent on a pole and they were healed
they looked and they lived it's so
simple
you look at jesus on the cross for your
sins believe that he's there to forgive
you he says that he makes us his sons
and his daughters you accept that
it should give you a peace and then
because we love him we will want to obey
him
and as you continue to claim that
promise his spirit will grow and swell
in your heart
if it doesn't happen
keep keep believing keep striving keep
praying
and it will happen you seek him with all
your heart the promise is jeremiah 29 13
you will search for me and you'll find
me when you search for me with all your
heart
you know we've got a book pass today one
that i like to share it's a great book
it's called three steps to heaven and it
talks about growing in grace the
experience of well experiencing that new
heart that's promised in the bible we'll
be happy to send this book to anyone who
asks the number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
three steps to heaven we'll be happy to
send it to anyone in north america if
you're outside of north america just go
to the amazing facts website you'll be
able to read it online at our free
library they're at amazingfacts.com or
amazingfacts.org
we've got deb listening in texas there
welcome to the program
hi thank you pastors good evening first
i'd like to tell you i really enjoyed
the summit this weekend with revelations
final warning oh wonderful
my question is this
if god and yeshua
are one and the same
then how is it that the son doesn't know
the day or the hour of the end of times
yeah in matthew 24 when jesus is talking
about his
return he said but of that day and that
hour knows no man but the
father only not even the son
and maybe he told the disciples that
also so that they want to be prodding
him to say exactly what is the date but
i believe when jesus was on earth he
didn't know the date because
christ laid aside a lot of his divine
knowledge
when he walked on earth among men
and so a god he lived by faith that god
would reveal his father would reveal to
him what he needed to know at the time
he needed to know
you can be quite certain that jesus does
know the day and the hour of his coming
now
he is you know at the right hand of the
father i'm sure if jesus where to say
father what's the date god's not going
to cover a piece of paper with his hand
and say i can't tell you it's a secret
it's just why he was on earth the bible
tells us and is it philippians that he
made himself of no reputation taking the
form of a man or that colossians and
yeah he laid aside his divinity
and
that's why he didn't know at that time
so deb does that make sense
yes you've cleared it up for me i
understand now he does know
well thank you appreciate thank you so
much pastors all right you have a good
evening
all right next quarter that we have is
andre in
canada andre welcome to the program
so
my question
in the beginning god created two persons
i am and i am assuming that they were of
the same race
so do you guys have an explanation why
we have so many different races today
yeah i think i don't think it's really
complicated first of all yes there was
one race
and the bible tells us in uh the book of
acts
god has made of one blood all nations
and the fact is it doesn't matter
whether you are asian or aborigine or
african or american indian some people
have got o positive blood and some
people have b positive blood and the
various blood types
and if
if i
have a car accident i need a transfusion
the race of the person won't make any
difference what they're going to look at
is the blood type
and
the reason that you've got different
races is because as people begin to
migrate around the world following the
tower of babel it's just a law of
genetics
that different people in different
environments when they're marrying
within a certain gene pool
that different traits will become more
dominant
and you can see this and forgive me for
making the comparison
but i believe that god originally made
two dogs two probably wolf like dogs
and look at all the different varieties
of dogs every shape and color and size
and
no hair lots of hair teeny tiny huge
they all come from the same dogs but
through
isolation in their breeding
you get all these different varieties
so god he built just a wonderful bouquet
of potential into these creatures so
that you can
you can have all different varieties
that arise out of the genes
and that's why you've got all these
different races
they were isolated and they different
traits became more dominant as they
married
hope that helps a little bit andre does
that make sense
yes thank you all right thanks so much
all right next quarter that we have is
james listening in georgia james welcome
to the program we have just about two
minutes yes hi hi
i i grew up in a really big church i'm
not going to name the religion but
they baptize you when you're a baby
and i don't believe that was really
valid according to everything that i
read the bible
and so i
i had a health issue
and i said god uh i want to turn my life
over to you
i will repent of my sins and i want to
ask you to come into my heart
uh water baptized but i i think i'm
already spiritually baptized uh and i
wanted to ask about that all right well
let me talk to you about that real quick
we just have a few minutes left or a few
seconds actually
please go to the amazing facts website
take the free amazing facts bible study
course we have one lesson that is
specifically on baptism you can read
that for free even right now at our
website and it's talk about
power and purity power and purity yes
and it'll tell you about the importance
of water baptism that is biblical but
you need both you need to be born of the
water born of the spirit and it'll also
guide you in the choice of a church
where you can be a 100 percent
absolutely committed christian i can
just hear the holy spirit is working in
your heart matthew and i'm hoping that
you're going to follow through with this
decision god is guiding you and you know
what if we didn't answer your whole
question this week give us another
chance next week you've been trying so
long just call early and we'll get you
on the program friends we have run out
of time for tonight's broadcast we hope
that you'll go to the amazing facts
website and use our resources
amazingfacts.org and we'll look forward
to hearing from you god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
for our friends of stay by we're going
to take some of your bible questions
that you have emailed to us we have
about two minutes past the doc so we
want to get as many of these questions
in as possible okay so here we go the
first question is divorce always
considered a sin or are there exceptions
and if so what are they
well usually all divorce somebody sinned
so
but it's possible for a person to be
what you would call an innocent party if
one spouse violates the marriage vows
through adultery
um they're guilty but the other person
has a right to divorce at that point
doesn't mean they have to but that's one
grounds for divorce and then in first
corinthians chapter seven it talks about
when
when two
pagans one of them becomes a christian
that the unbeliever may choose to
divorce and leave
the believer may not have any choice in
those cases
but so that would be one example okay
another question that we have it says
what countries still need to be reached
with god's truth
well the gospel is going into all the
world now through the internet and
various forms of media
but some places what they call the 1040
window
you know especially in the middle east
some of the islamic countries the gospel
it's still not freely proclaimed there
and now it's even getting hard to reach
people in europe it's becoming very
secular so
you can't say that everyone's had a
chance yet
okay another question we have it's
what is the best way to handle a very
difficult loved one or individual who
does not believe
yeah that's one of the ways we develop
character is by showing love to those
who sometimes can be difficult pray that
god gives you patience and wisdom and
pray for them share information if
they're willing to look at the
information and ask god to help you be a
good example to them
and it might be god growing you as you
try to love them
alright another question is omnicron the
third plague
the third plague of revelation
uh no i don't think so matter of fact
from what i'm hearing omnicron is very
virulent but it's not very deadly
uh it is spreading but it's the death
ratio is much smaller the the plagues
that you see in revelation um
there's not going to be any doubt about
what those plagues are and of course
those plates don't fall until after
probation closes yeah that's the land we
haven't had the blood in the water yet
so okay
all right well pass the doug again i
don't think we have time to take any
more questions but we want to thank
those for tuning in those who stayed by
if we didn't get to your question make
sure that you tune in next week you can
email or text your question to us and
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
absolutely god bless friends thank you
again for tuning in and if you are
blessed by these programs let us know
you can go to the website and donate to
keep us on the air
amazingfacts.org god bless
you